I was gonna ask you what the biggest
change has been but I feel like I can
see it trend right here it's happening
I'm pregnant so this is probably the
biggest change for me
um and then being engaged planning a
wedding
it's it's like I'm all grown up now well
your fiance we solve him on the show
Cory was on the show for a hot second
Lauren and I were living in the
apartment together and we were having a
Halloween party and I invited Corey and
then we went on our very first date on
camera which is the most awkward thing
in the world I want to go and you want
to go on it's already awkward enough you
have cameras around you especially for
him cuz he wasn't used to any of that so
I think we went on like another date and
then they wanted drama cuz it was like
Cory was a little shy I mean I was like
we can't I can't do that to him like no
and so I kind of told him like we're
gonna film one more time I'm gonna kind
of let you go because I don't want to
involve you in what's going on or about
to happen
mm-hmm and he understood so I let him
off nicely right now someone else still
has my heart so you guys had a fake
breakup for the show yeah I've been more
justin drama and then more justin drama
yeah I just I didn't feel Cory was such
a good guy and I was like he's so nice I
like it's not fair to involve him in all
this drama